here's a very hard Vector question what  is the ratio of o n to NB  we'll solve this problem with the  coordinate system of the vectors A and B  so o is 0 0 a is one zero and B is 0 1.  m is the midpoint of a b so it will be  equal to 0.5.5 then op to pm has a ratio  of three to two so p is equal to 3 over  5 of o plus M and that works out to be  0.3.3 from here the vector AP has  coordinates of negative 0.7.3 then let N  be the coordinates 0 R so a n will be  equal to negative one comma R but a n is  also equal to a multiple K of the vector  AP setting up this equation and  distributing through we can see that  we'll solve that K is equal to ten over  seven this means that R is equal to 3  over 7 so the coordinates of n are zero  comma three over seven  this means that o n is equal to 3 over  7B and B is equal to 4 over 7B so the  ratio o n to NB is equal to 3 to 4.